[Music]
and innocent till proven guilty news on
Aden Jamali emitted by fried or grilled
chicken fried all all the way fried all
the surgeons of fried chicken I see a
million different shops opening up now
really yeah there's one on a Fremont
it's called [ __ ] something yep I
heard about that place there's another
one called running chicks we remember
our running chicks oh that's on Atlantic
and I saw another one open up dude okay
by taking Islam there's a lot of fried
chicken [ __ ] it it's [ __ ] something
healthy fried chicken that wants and
healthy choice chicken
my biggest if I fried chicken if it
doesn't beat church's chicken I don't
want that [ __ ]
Louisiana Louisiana fried chicken is the
best Luisi magic is good too but
sometimes I don't want anything
oh I feel like I like churches better
than Luiza
I like seasoning yeah
a couple now has to pay 1 million
dollars and damages at the trashing
their wedding photographer over $125
fees in traction yeah they like
destroyed his business hmm
latest story in the business yep yeah
extra mascara on the ground
I'll confused okay you trash the person
they beat the [ __ ] out of him and I
think they got a DSLR through his lens
in the [ __ ] River oh I gave them back
to buddy
no mean Andrew and mealy he's bleeding
that's my job and ruin me Neely got
married in Dallas right through from
Mellie no taste these people he's only
down a segment
yes dub yes so they hired Andrea as
their photographer and so she's very
successful she's booked months in
advance so they know you know she does
good work and so three months after the
wedding the couple went to the press
with an empty with empty picture frames
saying that their wedding photographer
was holding their photos ransom
demanding an extra 150 dollars after
they had already paid thousands
if they were telling the press and so
Andrea at that time she refused to go on
camera with the press but she did
provide like a really long email
explaining the entire situation so good
but the email is not included in the
press coverage and this photographer
Andrea she's just thinking that the
media rather like the whole narrative of
the poor couple being scanned by the way
photographers [ __ ] the media man except
for just kidding news oh yes so then
that local public they all immediately
turn on Andrea and they started calling
her a scam artist and her entire
reputation was ruined for example are
down her business that's not people are
so happy so did she sue both the news
and these couple she should do both
because one is defamation and one it's
like you don't [ __ ] up man so she is
yeah she did through the couple and so
she's claiming that all they had to do
is fill out one last form selecting the
options of their wedding album and then
pay the final fee which they had already
known about and so like even in the
contract it states right there in bold
the final steps so they knew what they
were getting themselves into
and so she when she sued them she showed
the court the emails between her staff
and a couple trying to please a couple
as this as it could and she even
presented the whole argument that this
whole this whole frenzied media frenzy
was just to push the bride's beauty blog
and so she's just saying that you know
this is defamation and you're not only
that but she said it was customary to
hold the final resolution photos until
after the final payment exactly because
that's the only thing you have on them
if I read them like people if they did
that they would run away and never pay
yeah and so the Court determined that
the couple there's a couple of
heartbreaking tale was completely false
and so the jurors concluded that the
allegations constituted malicious
decimation and so they or the court
ordered the couple to pay 1 million
dollars Oh
yeah yes I hope they get a divorce too
shady people should never [ __ ]
combine forces because they're going to
[ __ ] make a shady family and they're
going to go around scanning people I
[ __ ] will murder them you got fired
oh just molesters pedophiles con artists
shady little scammers all of them all of
them die in my world yes alone they have
this statement says quote we are stunned
we did what consumer advocates say to do
when you are wronged you fight back we
were unhappy with a situation so we
complain like anyone would this court
decision tells consumers not to speak up
for fear of fat legal you don't go to
the press
you had your dumb [ __ ] what do you
[ __ ] talking about oh my god so
prepare that legal building people
painful judgments if this is the cost of
standing up for what's right we should
have given in to start no you [ __ ]
[ __ ] but we hope to prevail in the end
we love nothing more than to put this
behind us and focus on raising our five
month-old child oh don't put all don't
we see that that's why I'm like oh your
fight was won that takes their fingers
and just bend it backwards until it
cracks
ten times she is the best part of rebel
where the couples on the right
oh she looks evil ah
we love your mommy here we're not little
place from Star Trek Orson she was like
an alien and a couple severity is so
hard to be on their side because
everything that they're talking about is
just standard you know yeah pretty
tender system everyone that's had a
waiting problem they know that this is
there is a final fee there is you know
you have to they hold the photos until
you complete the payment like that's
just normal any photographer like you're
not going to get your [ __ ] pills
until you pay them yeah they've already
done all the
work yeah you know who's gonna be get on
the contract they spell it out like how
much you have to pay yeah and then
there's there shouldn't be any hidden
fees you know like that's ridiculous
it's hard to do men dealing with like
when I was doing like wedding
photography dealing with bridezillas are
one of the most difficult things you'll
ever do in your [ __ ] life because of
something even if you set expectations
right it doesn't [ __ ] matter there
was this one girl this okay so the lady
was on the rotund side so that she was
fat right listen your [ __ ] I can't do
[ __ ] if you're fat so we shot to her
exact specification she she was so like
anal retentive she wanted to her photos
were set at specific places specific
time she knew exactly what she wanted
which is actually great for us because
then we don't have to think so we did it
she goes well I'm fat in all these
pictures I might as well guess what
[ __ ] you're fat in real life yeah what
the [ __ ] do you want us to do about that
right and so as a joke I was like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm never going to wedding
photography ever again
she's like my last client I trimmed down
her waist I did everything like the time
where she was like super skinny right
loved it I love the [ __ ] photo she
look that's all I wanted oh no you look
like a [ __ ] monster are you kidding
me right now we wanted all the chains in
the background to vongole but we added
like bring down her waist and take out
the fat in her arms it didn't even look
like her but that's what she wanted but
it's hard to deal with that just so I
completely honest specifically a wedding
photographer I commend her that's it
it's rough bridezillas do those people
exist
Anna was doing tuxedos too at the time
oh you're like planning so I got to do
both sides but I got my wedding
photography up through that [ __ ] so
double-digit you're like a one-man
wedding in officiate you send visitor to
suit you could die needed money
oh that's crazy I love the Karma or like
the final justice it's like you could
just say $150 but nah ha ha playing a
million yeah that's all I love it
Oh a million dollars I hope oh not so
bad no I don't
are they ballin is that why they can the
judge can make them pay that much yeah I
know the same I don't know it's a
different living it may be they
calculated how much damage they did to
house matter how much that business made
potential customers that they probably
shut the entire business down because of
them yeah what are you photographers if
they're if they're good and they're
pretty well renowned they make a lot of
money they work generally about three to
four months out the year I'm like
roughly in terms of like how busy it is
and if you're and if you feel like
you've been done wrong you should always
contact the business and communicate
with them and if you can't find a
resolution instead of going to the
public just sue that you let the courts
decide you know yeah go into the
presence like the [ __ ] way out just
[ __ ] you gotta fight rally people up
so my thing is right after the fact like
let's say you do the court [ __ ] it's
been happening and you're actually in
the right and then some time passes then
you can report that I'm gonna be the
emails was what I wanted me to see what
what happened in the email so that they
were like extremely accommodating oh my
god I would be so pissed but other are
the wedding photos anywhere that would
be C I know I was I wanted to see some
seriously like the only photos that they
had of their wedding we're like taking
some like friends I don't even have to
gotta pay 1.5 and you don't got memories
of their wedding oh yeah they better not
get those photos oh yeah
so all the wedding photos is from a
phone and [ __ ] we're getting gold damn
did you guys feel like you're waiting
with smooth yeah you're an awesome I
think it was perfect moment so and you
said there's one thing that didn't but
you to do it again no I mean well okay
David a better heads-up on the feel bad
but I will tell my good now I showed you
more than once okay
no but anyways I'm just trying to keep
you sharp you know maybe work out
beautifully dude okay we did not well
remember back in the day she kind of so
there's no funny thing so yeah I do
remember her telling me she was like
twice right but telling somebody can you
do it and it yes is not preparing me to
do the wedding you know I mean because
we have to have a conversation like I
had with you guys how do you want it
done what do you you know I mean there's
like a whole step of the process I
thought what I assume was Oh like I
guess she didn't need me you know but my
defense I don't know what the hell I
needed I've never not married before I
thought you might have told me like okay
we need to do this I didn't know
anything's I'm like cool you can do it
cool you can do it so what happened was
like I got a boutonniere right yeah
don't play what if I go get a
boutonniere hear that again and then job
came up to me and then he was like even
more suspicious because he bought the
boutonniere oh my god come you get one
an idol he was like I don't know what he
thought of playing with it in the
flowers right and you look up [ __ ] yeah
I can also like sure to be attached
though it just threw it in a bush and
then he told me that he saw something
with my name on it yeah and in the
wedding planner are you David and I'm
like no and I was like why is she
looking for David like what all happen
the day off but they are
then I was like David you're doing the
thing right and then you're like what
I'm like Jeb the wedding planner is
asking for you should probably think
you're doing it but if they started to
click I was like poopoo here lie and I
look at everybody else like he has a
boutonniere
I believe important people like
everybody is important to boutonniere
and so that's what I walked up a man I
want to see me Christmas and then I was
like on my stomach drop - I was like I
was like ha ha ha bro you see the sauce
so literally before you're walking out
like buy this before this is me on the
side yeah yeah I feel bad but again I
did it no it won't sound upset
yeah that's exactly what it was you
close it you did beautifully oh [ __ ]
what am I gonna do you know that was dog
Zoey
hey you came through you came through
yeah no and then the wedding planner
even went up to your right so what if I
get that she goes oh my god I don't know
it was comments cuz I've known you guys
so long so I already had a lot of
backstory I just needed it to be
cohesive and makes sense you know but I
was like nervous and after they got
married and everybody went inside I took
a nap outside for an hour
oh I feel like the stress though was I
like a migraine that Muriel like taking
my head until I fell asleep you
shouldn't use The Hangover kid there was
a friend of man I didn't we took that
basket no beyond the one thing that I do
want to know the whole way my thing
that's kind of like we hired like
satellites have come in to livestream
and then a kept glitching and it was
like well it got a lot of the stuff in
there though it was good yeah yeah it
stopped right during the middle of the
vows
oh yeah I cut out I cast about and then
the speeches were gone from the last
room go all the same that I was cracking
up because remember this old Jake can
use episode this was my partner
bullfrogs a [ __ ] that our whole family
was at all Mexican made like the [ __ ]
like French beret I thought it crushed
to go get them all I could think about
this
hello everybody if you liked the video
make sure that you guys leave us a
thumbs up because if not I'm gonna find
you where you live and I'm gonna hug the
[ __ ] out of you with people other than
that you know it's like more videos up
there bro
[Music]